we're at CES 2016 and one of the best
things I've seen so far is this new
camera from Boris
it's the snap it's a really simple
little camera there's no LCD screen on
the back there aren't a lot of features
on the top but it's a printing camera so
what you do is just hit this to turn it
on you have some options to go between
black and white sepia or color and then
it prints out the side here so it's only
known $99 which is really cheap for a
camera that prints there's going to be
another version called the snap plus and
that will have an LCD screen on the back
as well as connectivity so you can do
things like use it as just a standalone
printer and send photos from your phone
you're gonna have to buy the paper you
load it in the back here but it's the
same paper so it's really easy to find
on Amazon and most retailers it's just a
few little Cameron I think it's per
month